[Music]
you know to your point the visas the
mastercards they have so much power so
much anointing power so much gateway
power but all they can do is slow it
down the cat's out of the bag
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
let's start with nfts those non-fungible
tokens our audience our readers and
listeners are so interested in those
you've been very busy creating and
issuing your own nfts and selling them
most recently you sold your collection
of of doodles and sketches for over a
million dollars at auction at christie's
you started an nft platform with julian
schnabel called art official what is it
gary about nfts that has you so
enthusiastic what are they telling us
about the future about collectibles
about authenticity
i think people are underestimating what
digital ownership means no different
than i think people underestimated what
having a social media account meant you
know i don't think you know this we're
both of the age where
a human having a social media account
was foreign that was not something
people did
and
today
you know most people do even if they
have it anonymously to keep tabs on
people or use twitter to keep up with
the news or occasionally check facebook
for
you know birthdays you know a shocking
amount of society is active on social
and even bigger percentages consuming it
and
i don't you know as somebody who was
there in 2005 67 people didn't see it
that way they saw it as
for kids they saw it as who cares if
you're having a piece of pizza or
walking the dog
and i think the exact same thing is
happening right now in nft land i think
people are
misunderstanding
why everyone's going to want to own
something digitally
you know you have all these cool things
behind you as we're filming this
there's a reason you want those things
expressing yourself decorating your home
memory to something there's a million
different
investment scenarios and i think that
people don't understand that nfts
represent many things um but from an
investment standpoint
people want to have digital assets and
they're going to trade those digital
assets
i also think it goes beyond that i think
the reason somebody owns a rolex versus
a regular watch a pair of nikes besides
a regular joggers
a a mercedes-benz instead of a ford
is because of status and expressionism
and and then there's the overarching
aspect that it is a public
transparent ledger confirmed by
with no cost association in comparison
to leases and mortgages and all the
other things and so
um to me this is a foregone conclusion
to me it's similar to 95 internet life
though
um you know i think
much like we saw on the internet there
was a lot of public stocks that made no
sense
that were worth a lot of money
pets.com becoming the poster child and i
think the same thing is happening in nft
project land i think
the nft thing is going to happen and i
want v friends to be amazon or at least
ebay right
uh and they were there as dollar stocks
back when everything crashed and i think
the same thing's happening in ft land
the macro concept is here in perpetuity
on the micro
i do believe we're in a gold rush moment
right now and there are a lot of people
buying nfts
that
will not be as valuable as they pay for
them
and
that's a
treacherous thing to navigate through
the macros right and there's an amazon
and ebay at it there oh by the way eight
out of ten of them are pets.com how you
gonna figure that out there's a lot of
ways to play it if you're high risk high
reward you're buying the individual
stuff
if you're a little bit different you're
looking at the whole landscape and
deciding where you want to be a
participant selling the shovels and the
picks
uh
buying individual projects you know for
example i've spent a lot of money on
crypto punks
and
i feel like it's my most safe investment
i own really genuinely i'm that
convinced that that project the og
project the one that kind of established
the 10 000
images
framework the one that is owned by many
important people and collectors
is uh
is
incredibly sound and i think the bottom
floor of that is four hundred thousand
dollars a piece right now
and so you know this is how i think
about things what does it conceptually
mean metaphysically mean in a world
where everything's digital things can be
faked how important is the authenticity
that signature this is a gary vee
original uh to the value of things
looking forward out a decade or so
i mean it's everything right i mean
that's that was the vulnerability of uh
of the
world we live in today
there was fakes
there's no fakes
in nft land um it's incredibly powerful
and providences understood and who owned
it and
the transparency matters
you know christies and sotheby's are
respected and accepted
but it's human-based they can only be so
right it's inconceivable to me
that there haven't been fake things sold
through the greatest auction houses in
the world
with what you're doing with nf keys each
one of these tokens you recently sold
with the v friends collection includes a
smart contract with the metadata that
that you can interact with the buyer
with right these they can get exclusive
access i'm reading to an annual business
event called vcon for three years this
is more than just buy something that i
created because i'm garyvee here's my
digital signature it's a one one-of-one
you're creating community with them is
that where this is headed to
reality is is that i'm i feel this is
more walt disney than it is andy warhol
i'm trying to build an intellectual
property
tv film
action figure this than the other thing
and you know these tokens are the
original cells right
there and and i can create value of
creation as i keep adding value to
the ticket holders the token holders
the
nft holder so it's an economy that
you're building as a creator of nfc
project
i think we can all agree that bitcoin is
probably dramatically more far along
than what many would have predicted it
to be
eight nine years ago
and that itself has to right when you
have visa mastercard allowing you to
transact when you have the biggest money
managers allowing you to invest in
crypto or pathways to that we're here
right
i believe so and i believe we're here
on the consumer lens
you know to your point the visas the
mastercards
the biggest trading firms
they have so much power so much
anointing power so much gateway power
but all they can do is slow it down
right people want it the count the cat's
out of the bag what's the natural
extension of influence marketing as you
see it well i you know i think
what a lot of influencers are going to
do now is and we've seen this
progression it went from
you know just building up a following
and monetizing offline
a book deal speaking i live that back to
my original influencer world
then you started getting into the
monetization of the ads right the
youtube ad revenue started becoming
quite meaningful
then you started getting into brand
deals
brands started to compensate influencers
and there are plenty of people who make
seven figures a year being a human being
on social and having brands pay them
money to endorse them no different than
mickey mantle
or john wayne just an influencer fall
then you started seeing
you know
them influencers are starting to build
businesses like i did with empathy wines
you know
eight nine figure exits for influencers
who built a company on the back of their
audience
and now i think you'll see in nft land
people build
you know ecosystems you know
financial
vehicles uh
economies around them and i think that's
where we're going
let's talk about investing which is our
domain you've been a pretty savvy
investor and you've been an early
investor in some very successful public
companies given what we've seen gary in
the past 18 months millions of new
traders and investors joining the market
through the robin hoods the etoros the
weebles or even a classic online broker
how is that game changing now that we
have this very uh engaged retail base
it changes a lot
you know you've got a lot
more
casual
investors many of whom
view it as a vehicle for
community
many of them who view it as
social
gaming
is what i would use you know like people
buying to gain the dynamics
we're seeing investing as an identity
we've seen that with entrepreneurship as
a decade now yeah
is somebody we all know that's right so
i think i think that a couple things on
that one
there's also a lot of naivete and
ideology and lack of education which can
lead to huge vulnerability
so you know a lot of the
kids they like me and i keep pushing
them like be thoughtful you know like
get educated
um but i think you know it it speaks
well i actually think
it's probably one of the biggest reasons
i'm bullish on nfts
i i still believe that the way nfts are
going to play out is somebody's going to
be more excited to show you they're
holding an x copy
or a crypto punk
than holding 17 shares of tesla
let's talk about how you identify
investments that you want to make public
or private public companies private
companies businesses you get into what's
your criteria what are your basics that
you put everything through when you look
at that prism
do i believe in the hypothesis that
consumers will like this and do i
believe the human being that's driving
it is capable of driving it or adjusting
to reality
this is as simple as it gets and i have
a knack for understanding consumers
which already puts me in a very good
spot on hypothesis
i also have a very strong understanding
of timing
one thing that i've understood now in
hindsight when i look at my success is
oh
i'm good at timing like when all my
friends are like investing in vr
i understand that vr is gonna happen but
i i was
stronger than them four years ago saying
vr is further away than you think let's
talk about the the last year year and a
half what influenced you the most in the
past year what did you change about the
way you operate as a as an executive or
as a father as a person uh given the
last year that we've been through or so
before kovid i started
being self-aware that lack of candor as
an executive and a leader
gary vee the person everybody knows on
the other side
strength was candor
people loved that i quote unquote shot
at straight on stage in meetings
but me on one on one
in every relationship on and off the
field of business
i struggled with deploying critical
feedback or negative feedback
i tried to
get around it with
optimism oftentimes met with delusion
and
over the last three years i've really
chipped away at it and my new book
that's coming out in november
i called it 12 and a half it was about
these 13 emotional ingredients that i
think are
essential for business success as a
leader or as an employee
and
i call it 12 and a half because kind
candor is one of them but i go very
vulnerable and say i'm only at a half on
this one
and
that's the biggest thing i've changed i
think i'm through going through a put a
positive journey
around candor
well you not only preach empathy in your
business and you have the wine but i
know for a fact that you practice it as
a leader as a father and as a friend
when did you come to that realization
and how has it made you better
early
i i knew as a child that
i was nicer than most people that i was
more compassionate i didn't have the
words of empathy
i knew i was more sensitive i
legitimately recall
crying or being on the verge of tears
when kids would pick on kids who had
disabilities or
were poor you know i grew up in a pr my
first
several years of
america i grew up in lower middle class
environments you know you find yourself
in those environments there's some kids
that are even less fortunate than you
wearing the same clothes to school i was
always very sensitive i cried a lot
i had a lot of emotions and feelings but
they were my superpower and i knew
as i got older and older and older
it became very clear to me how to
harness it
and
i'm so proud of my compassion and
empathy and sympathy and
feelings towards others it you know i
love that i get such a
sense of happiness by delivering for
others it's a
it's a beautiful
lucky
i want to use that word it's just my dna
it is a beautiful but it was count you
know and then even my mother who
accentuated it there's luck in having
that mother right like
i'm incredibly grateful
for the circumstances that led me to be
very passionate about other people's
feelings seeing the arbitrage and seeing
around corners something you have done
ever since i met you years and years ago
and it's been a real pleasure to know
you and and watch what you've been able
to build but also the person that you've
become gary vaynerchuk thanks so much
for joining the express so good to have
you here thanks caleb